we're standing here outside of isiam
which was one of the biggest cities
recaptured in the rapid ukrainian
defensive and president zolensky was
here visiting the troops and taking a
tour of the scene
the view is
very shocking but it's no shock for me
because
we
we
began to see
the same
pictures from bucha
from the first the occupied territories
so the same destroyed buildings killed
people
and so
what can i say
[Music]
is
[Music]
trenches like these were used by
russians just a few days ago and they're
littered with remnants of the russian
forces
they had left weapons ammunition that
the ukrainians have taken a hold of and
are now distributing to their troops
the collapse of the russian defenses
here which they had held for about six
months really surprised a lot of the
ukrainian forces that that we talked to
they expected the russians to really dig
in that's really not what happened
the main thing that not me here our
soldiers here that is very important
thing that
it support supports people i see how
people
uh
meet them
that is you know
very sensitive moment
[Music]
lots of civilians who were forced to
flee that are now slowly returning to
the area so the ukrainians are moving
forward and clearing up this area now
that the russians have moved back
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
you